hey guys i'm amanda and i'm seth and i'm
samuel and together we are
samantha no no no that's not happening
hey welcome back to this week's episode
i am here with my wife amanda hey guys
and last time we did this we spoke with
you and we asked you for suggestions in
terms of
what should be the name of our podcast
a video we have some interesting names
what kind of names are we having we had
leading the way leading the way with
double a yeah doubly
which is kind of cool i think we've come
to
a conclusion i think i think
well you were saying the leads family
yeah the lead family
and i was saying money marriage and life
so i think maybe together
the leads family money marriage in life
could be the one
still 100 decided let us know what you
think before we before we go official
the leads family money marriage and life
is that a good name for our podcast
if you think it is then we can literally
start putting this on spotify and
google and all the places where you know
that's probably where i don't uh but in
the meantime
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe smash the like button
drop a comment below any questions that
you have for me and amanda about money
marriage or life comment below and we'll
do our best to answer but in the
meantime we'll offer you up to this week
this week um another cool good week with
the kiddies
um we went to the fair on saturday so
that was really fun with the kids
ruby she's our eldest girl and she's
three years old and
she's just growing up so fast babe like
i know
oh she asked me today why luke doesn't
have to go to school i know she goes to
preschool
school but it's so weird having a proper
conversation
with i know it is amazing she was a baby
not long ago and
she said the sweetest thing to me she
just looked at me
oh my gosh oh i came here amanda was
crying
and she said and i was like ruby just
looked at me and she said mommy
you're my best friend oh my gosh my
heart
melted oh well do you think she actually
knew what it meant or do you think she
was just parroting what you say to her
no of course she meant it but she
it's just so sweet just seeing how fast
she's growing up she's literally she's
just a little girl now she's not a baby
i thought was really sweet about ruby
was when when we go in the hot tub
um we sometimes have like a baby monitor
so we can hear what's going on yeah
and with jessica our youngest we can see
them but it's just so that we can hear
just in case you think we've like left
them upstairs um
we're only about to hear them and we
have got like someone in the house with
them as well so
yeah we're not bad parents honestly but
we have a baby monitor so we can hear
jessica
but uh we was there and we heard jessica
she was making little queuing noises but
then ruby came over to him i was like
you okay jessica are you okay and it's
been really sweet to her and i just
thought we have got
we're so blessed we've got wonderful
kids i know yeah so yeah so i'm just
enjoying
every moment especially right now
because jessica's a baby so i'm totally
just full-on
mommy mode like so are you like someone
asked in the questions thank you by the
way for the questions last week yeah it
helps so much when you ask questions
so that i don't have to think up
questions so like would you rather
questions
yeah yeah thank you so comment away and
ask in in the comment box any questions
at all for amanda or for me or both of
us
um but someone asked last week
whether you were like a full-time qs
still
no no no i'm not i'm not so i stopped
qsing it was 2016
um when i left my corporate job so yeah
i'm
just right now i'm full-time mummy but i
do work on our property business as well
yeah i mean your full-time mom at the
moment that's because you've got
we've got like a newborn yeah yeah yeah
you know breast feeding and everything
but i still do things but yeah i'm not
like
you know it's mostly just like but
before jessica was born you were like 50
50 you were doing like 20 hours a week
on business
yeah and then with the property stuff
and then like 20 hours
well not 20 hours a week the rest is 24
7.
yeah yeah but all right cool so my week
what have i been up to
um i've been away a lot this week
i've been to newcastle which is so far
it's like
i don't envy you with all that driving
like samuel doesn't mind driving i
am not a fan so like driving to
newcastle's just like it makes me tired
you're thinking of going electric but i
just think
i need a comfy range rover that massages
you with a fridge
because of the amount of driving that i
have yeah you live in your car
so much and i really do think it's so
frustrating because when we were living
in the midlands
i was always in london i was always in
london i was in under like
twice three times a week and i liked
london so we decided to move to
buckinghamshire
and we're really close to london we kind
of are we southerners now
we're living it kind of can yeah um and
now we moved i'm always up north
i'm always so i think the answer to my
problems
is a car that massages me or hopefully
one day
i really do think we should contemplate
a helicopter
yeah well it would save a lot of time it
would save so much time the problem is
with a helicopter is
it will be such an ordeal wouldn't it i
can just imagine it do you think i don't
think so
what he's going to do i went to
newcastle and i was thinking should i
just fly
it's an hour and a half on the yeah on
the plane it's five hours driving but if
you fly
you've got to get there oh they're gonna
be saying to you oh have you
got your covered this and this just let
me just get there i don't i don't like
yeah but yeah it's a bit inconvenient
however it saves a lot of time doesn't
it what about when i went to my hotel
oh my goodness so i booked samuel um
hotel
i think i can't remember i think it was
the hilton
samuel gets there so he has to show like
a letter to say that he's there for it
for work i hate all that stuff it's so
annoying
don't just take us out in liverpool i
went to liverpool
i got there to the hotel i was checking
in and they said to me um
do you have a letter from your workplace
saying that you are here for essential
work i'm like well i'm the
owner and the director of my work
company so i can just tell you that yes
i am
here for work okay but do you have a
letter though from your work
i'm like um hold on one minute so i just
emailed myself
a letter saying dear samuel you are here
for essential work
because according to the government
property market is open and you're here
and you have a viewing tomorrow
to view a property so you're here for
work regards samuel
right so i'm like there you go and
they're like oh yeah but um
that's that's just to yourself all right
but i am like
i was arguing with them for like half an
hour oh
my goodness oh my goodness
like what do you want and then in the
end that's it your amanda
amanda can you just write me an email
please saying i'm here for work reasons
and just
do a little you know a little signature
with the work the registration of the
company et cetera she sent to me and i
[ __ ] and they're like oh that's fine
then that's okay
i was trying to wait my yeah it's
annoying what happened was worse what
happened in newcastle
i don't even think i should tell a story
i think you should i think it's funny
because it's just so typical you but
anyway which way it's a typical way
okay okay what happens at the end of it
sir
what happened was samuel got there he's
really really tired he's been driving
for like five hours
you get there i've booked the hotel for
him and then
they're like asking for the letter fine
he gives them the letter
okay have a letter ready for i didn't
even ask me i was just like
here's my letter here's my i'm totally
up front i got there at 11 30. i left in
the afternoon i've been driving five
hours i was so tired when i got there i
just needed to sleep
yep and then and then he says okay so
where's the card that you
paid made the payment for for the hotel
so i'd use the business card
which samuel didn't have on it but it
was paid for the room also
i didn't i don't know why they're asking
you for the card so anyway samuel like
rings me it's like midnight and you're
like oh they're asking for the card and
i'm like well
i've got the card i was like i can
facetime you and show you that i've got
the card
the card is in samuel's name he's got id
showing the guy
his id so basically what they were
saying is i needed to show the card
physically the debit card that was paid
to book the hotel
right i'm like but i don't book my
hotels
either my workplace dude or my wife just
i don't book it i'm here i've got my id
i've got my letter
like what the hell and they're like oh
um i'm like
what do you mean you don't like i need
to sleep bro
let me in alan let me in bro like what
the heck and he's like no you knew
and i said is there any other way around
it's like well you could go to the cash
machine
and pay in cash like what
and then in the end he goes i said what
what i said what would i have paid on
another close oh you could do that i'm
like why don't you tell me that from the
road again
huh why are you telling me that you're
brave again why don't we have this
15-minute conversation back and forth
with you guys i don't know what to do
terrible customer service so i said i
said
i was like i was so tired i was like
okay so we're good now goes yeah here's
your key card to get in i'm like
why did you make such an ordeal and i
went to bed i got to bed and i thought
i rang him on reception i said excuse me
are you the guy that i just i was just a
reception with he said yeah i said
what's your name he said alan i said
what's your surname
it doesn't why does it matter i said
because i'm about to leave a review on
hilton hotel and i want to know your
full name
oh well i'm just alan the night manager
all right alan the night manager well
they know who that is good i'll leave
with you
bang left review just told the situation
and then the following morning um when i
checked out the lady was so nice she was
like a nice day she's so nice i just
thought
i've left a bad review but now she said
lovely i said everything's been amazing
i just wish you were here last night
i just hate inconvenience i just hate
you when people you know you're not a
fan
right it's worthy of something that
samuel does if we're right out somewhere
and we're in a shop and he's looking for
something
and he asks like one of the shop
assistants oh excuse me do you know
where this is and then they say hmm
and then they tell us where something is
and then we go and look and then the
thing's not where they said it was
oh no no what they do is when they say
something isn't in stock yeah so if i
say
hey do you have any baileys you know i'm
in the mood for a
glass of beige you have any bays or we
don't sell baileys oh
you don't sell bellies anywhere no no we
don't we don't sell babies here do you
know anywhere that does maybe go to
you know maybe go maybe go to tesco
because waitrose we don't do we don't
sell baileys i'm like
oh wow okay and then i feel like i have
to look anyway but sometimes
i find baileys yep and amanda's just
like okay
yeah i'm just like oh at least we found
it let's go let's play i'm like nah
samuel's like no no no and then i don't
know i don't kick off by the way
i probably sound like a dick right now i
don't know it's quite funny how you do
it because then he'll go
find that person that yeah yeah i'll
find them and then he's like hmm
oh what did you say again about the
baileys and then he'll hold on
yeah oh i actually found it it's on r17
and then the future they're usually
dumbfounded in just like
uh i just think it's so funny because i
just wouldn't do that but it's just when
you ask somebody where somebody is and
they don't take you to it they just go
oh i think it's around
near where the bread is and like just
take me man but i don't luckily i don't
go shopping very often i probably go
shopping
uh once or twice a year yeah you don't
go shopping anyway it's very rare it's
usually just
if you text me yeah and i'm on the way
back and you know could you just quickly
pick up some
and i get there and it's like a foreign
world to me i'm like where is everything
what's going on here
because i've never shopped even when i
used to live on my own i had someone
live not live with me but you would come
in
all the while stuck up do your watching
do my things for me
because my whole and i want we're going
to talk on this episode about time
management
because some people will be like samuel
why don't you just do it yourself
you know but i think it's really
important if you're going to grow a
business
if you want to make a lot of money to
outsource
stuff yeah that is like literally
shopping why go shopping why not just
online shop
because you can save so much time
because time is money
so that's what we're talking about in
this episode yeah can you confirm that i
am not not a dick
no samuel's not dick i do it in a nice
just laugh after because you do it with
like a humor you do a nice life
unless they're really really bad to me
yeah if someone's a real
douchebag to me then i can be back but
generally speaking
i'm a peacemaker you're definitely a
peacemaker
i'm such a peacemaker by by nature like
i hate confrontation hate conflict
i try and like keep keep them i believe
there's a time and a place for
everything
and sometimes you have to just let it go
it doesn't matter but other times
like with some of our bridging companies
yeah i'm like
get me on the they're so what about that
bridging company oh my gosh is this one
bridging company that i know many deals
with the sort of stuff you ever
want to deal with ever again in my life
they were like the most
like i'm quite laid back and i don't get
angry really fast but they
oh my gosh i had it up to here with them
they were just natural what did they do
they tried to make us pay back why not
yeah we already paid 100 grand and then
there were things yeah
it was just they sent us an outstanding
balance they were terrible
yeah they were they were so annoying
just thinking about it
so time management how do you have the
time to be
a mama to be a business owner a wife to
juggle all these things i mean
you know for me i've got a training
company i do a youtube video every day
time management top tips go
oh wow top tips and at the end by the
way don't forget i'm going to ask you
your
final word of wisdom
at the end you should just have like
five or six years you
got me you got i didn't remind you i'm
gonna ask you well you only reminded me
now
yeah before we started filming because
the whole thing is like kind of
happening oh my goodness okay so time
management
time manager how do you let me ask you a
question okay how do you manage to be
a full-time mom work on the business
do podcasts well like you put up with me
yeah oh i don't have to put up with you
okay so
um i'd say prioritizing but as you've
said first as well
outsourcing so outsourcing things that
you don't have to do what do you
what do you outsource so i outsource my
food shopping for example i get them to
come and deliver to me that's one
example
yeah also even just like child care
having someone that helps me with the
kids that's really really helpful
as well tell the story because you i
wanted to get someone like full-on
full-on
uh like just there kind of all the time
to help with the kids and help
clean this and never because like
initially
even the idea of having cleaners coming
you you're okay with just having
that when we were thinking of getting
someone to come and look after the kids
yeah i was like because i was the first
time you hated the idea i hated the idea
i was actually really nervous because i
was like
oh my gosh i thought if this person's
spending so much time with my child
what if my child actually starts to not
love them more than me but it's like
it's like competition for me and i was
just thinking oh it might be really
ah it might be really hard watching my
my kid
be all affectionate and all upon this
person and a lot of people told me they
were like
um oh but you don't want to miss the
moment yeah yeah
if you employ somebody to you know help
bring the kids up and do
like you want to enjoy and savor the
moment everyone said that people that
said that we usually broke people by the
way
like people in the family whatever who
broke so
however i mean how's it going the last
few years like we've got three kids
yeah it's amazing you love your kids
like an employee could never
yeah you know so i think you feel that
love and yeah quality time
so so i guess that's one way to save yes
so i'd say outsource
yeah but but also don't punish yourself
oh go on
don't punish yourself by thinking i have
to do this job
oh i really should i ought to
we have banned the word shouldn't or in
our family right yeah what what happens
if i say should
you say because [ __ ] is a disgusting
word i know
yeah just sure do it all done
i should don't be a martyr yeah you know
and i think people are martyrs in their
own companies as well
okay i'm gonna talk what you think of
the second point i've already got the
second point
yeah i've got a second point what did i
do so my first thing was outsourcing
um my second thing that i'd say is just
writing a list of prioritizing so
every day or every week i'll on my notes
i'll just
write to do and then i'll literally just
write a list of every single little
thing that i'm thinking that i need to
do that week
and then outsource it yeah outsource it
or if i can't outsource it then i have
to outsource it
and if i have to do it then i'll then
prioritize it as to what needs to get
done first or just or just scrap it
yeah scrap it
outsource it or do it yourself
yeah you know but mostly not do it
yourself there's very few things i
i i mean for me there's some things that
you think are or
two i probably should no for me my
attitude is
always replace yourself so i'm just
constantly replacing myself
and let's say i'm doing if i'm doing a
new job
i'll learn how to do it but then i'm not
going to keep doing it myself i'm just
going to
hire somebody to do it and then i would
it will free me to do something else
and then i'll do something else and then
i'll write a manual i'll systemize it
and then i'll replace myself and then
every now and then i'll jump in
but i jump into our customer service our
customer service right now
2021 without all our companies
is amazing like really fast really good
our average response time over emails is
three and a half hours which is great
because we get thousands of emails
like our customer service is really
really really good but what um
the different departments arsenals jump
in and do the job so i'm like right
i'm going to spend a week doing customer
service in my own company
so i'll do it i'll monitor the emails
i'll do everything customer service
and then i'll be like oh actually geez
we're not as good as i thought we can
make it better and i'll make it better
and then i'll write down and i'll update
the systems and the manual
training programs of our company retrain
the staff
hire the standards and move on to
another department you know so
i think it's just a case of doing um
as as as a company owner doing what only
you can do
not doing stuff that anyone else could
do you know would you yeah
yeah and you are the master of
delegation yeah i
i'm naturally not i'm naturally wanting
to do everything myself and you've kind
of taught me that
um like you don't have to do everything
so
yeah yeah it's about just important
getting it done but not doing it
yourself yeah even normal stuff like
around the house or
jobs like booking holiday you don't need
to do that you can
pay somebody to sort that out yeah um
and as well you need to know how much
you're worth per hour
if you're worth per hour 20 pound an
hour okay
let's say you get paid your salary you
know how much you're worth per hour
don't ever do a job
that you can pay somebody less than 20
pound an hour to do
you could find a lawn mower sorry not a
lawnmower a gardener
to cook your grass you pound 12 pounds
an hour
but if you're worth 20 pound an hour why
are you gonna be doing that job
you're gonna save eight pounds by
getting somebody else to do it and then
the more you
the more you start making and the more
successful you become the less
mundane stuff you're gonna do so i do
very few mundane stuff right yeah you do
very few
um so so i think that's probably the
best thing so when people say to me how
do you make it how do you manage your
time
how do you have a company and this and
this and be a dad and all these things
it's because
because i have a really good team you
know and hire people um just because you
are a quantity surveyor and an interior
designer
and seriously because you're an interior
designer
and of course doesn't mean that you're
gonna do all of our
interior design work and all of our
surveying on the property
business just because you can doesn't
mean that you will yeah so
yeah time management just outsource
stuff
have fun do quality things with the kids
but not everything
um but your family are really helpful as
well when we go away
yes yeah my family's really we don't
leave the kids with the nanny when we go
away
we we family moving family and thank god
we've got good family yeah so um
anything else on that point
no no wisdom no wisdom on that point i
actually need to think about my final
thoughts but anyway go on final fantasy
in the meantime i've got some questions
from you guys let's see we've got
read out the names so we have cleo jones
cleo jones says what's your favorite
gospel album
whilst i'm no fan of kanye west i was
unexpectedly impressed when i listened
to his gospel choir very gifted
so favorite gospel album go oh i'd
probably say i love lots of different
songs
um i'm gonna guess yours you can guess
mine oh your favorite gospel album is
hell songs
yeah okay anything that's hillsong
what's my favorite gospel music
yours godfrey birth godfrey birdsall
boomshacker that's right
godfrey bertillo oh
pretty much all i listen to is godfrey
burt hill he is the man
yeah um so incredible musician
he played at our wedding he did he did
we had him play our wedding so special
yeah i love godfrey burr hell so you
should check him out on youtube he's
kind of like um
he's different he's very different but
if you want to listen to some good
gospel music check out godfrey okay
ts questions for amanda are you fluent
in shauna
yes i am can you say something yes
um
oh my goodness
i just said i love you but you've got a
big head yeah um
yeah you you she speaks flinch on in
fact um amanda speaks fluent shauna
and you sometimes speak charlotte's the
kids you speak shauna with your parents
uh you moved to england when you were
ten yeah ten years old
so um is your mother tongue right it is
that's why
sometimes just struggle with her english
words a little bit oh my goodness
i do yeah you did
maybe an interesting fact about amanda
oh i have to say yeah well yeah or i can
say it
you say it because an interesting fact
about amanda
oh there's just so many i would say
an interesting fact about amanda is
she's ridiculously
neat and tidy and clean oh yes that's
true
that's true like absolutely everything's
perfect in the house all the time
because that you are yeah yeah yeah i am
a title in fact that was the one thing
that we thought we might argue about
because i am not yeah i am
samuel's quite messy when i when i lived
on my own before amanda i just had
somebody around me constantly cleaning
and tidying
up after him because i am just so
you you are you are so different in that
way we are
we really are but as it happens i think
it's fine
yeah you're not that bad now
like you just i think the thing that
yeah the thing that would annoy me the
most is just like lots of clothes on the
floor and stuff and you you
do pick pick up after yourself most of
the time
um yeah anyway um cheers also says
samuel is there a way to access your
dissertation on christianity and money
uh i think that's my struggle at the
moment um and do you still win your
christian course i like samantha no
samantha we're done we're not we're not
doing that but in terms of the books and
stuff
yeah so my my um biblical economic
studies i did put into a into a into a
book
which is called do the possible watch
god do the impossible which is on
amazon so you can check it out um yeah
have fun right next and a says
let's do a book club guys as part of
your podcast episodes every five or
something
thanks the kids are gonna love watching
this when they're older thanks andy yeah
we could do a book club i mean i read
i don't know if i go through phases
sometimes i'll read loads of books like
literally bang bang bang bang bang bang
and then i'll go months without reading
a book but
very happy to do book reviews and and
things for sure that would be cool yeah
yeah we can do that thanks for the
suggestion andy any more suggestions for
this
podcast comment below um okay
okay i hope i pronounced that right have
you read rich dad poor dad
um i actually haven't have you know yeah
wow
i actually haven't wow not okay i have
obviously
i'm shocked that you've not read rich
dad porn i know i know
it's just i've started it but i've never
finished it wow
so that's something you didn't know
about amanda that is crazy
um uh amanda do you still work as a
quantity surveyor we know the answer
i know being always a full-time job in
itself kind of canbe um all right next
number one super juicy amanda did you
think you would marry someone who was so
well known
i didn't think i'd marry someone who was
so well known no um
i don't know if you know our story i
actually thought that samuel was gonna
be a pastor
so i didn't think at all that um
you know he'd be that well known and
even when i did know like what he did
and stuff i didn't think that he'd be as
well known as he is so no never planned
on it someone says the podcast should be
called the beauty and the beast that's a
bit mean on you isn't it
baby don't talk about my wife that way
um all right so thank you so much for
listening i hope you enjoyed it
and before we close amanda final
words of wisdom
final words of wisdom off the top of my
head oh my goodness okay
i would probably just it wasn't you've
been thinking about it last twenty years
no
but we've been talking so i couldn't
think i can't think of talking
no no no no oh my god okay final words
of wisdom
is each day always find something to be
grateful for
because sometimes when you're in the day
and you're having a bad day
what you focus on expands yeah so if you
like just focusing on all the little
negative things it's never going to help
you're just going to get even more down
about it
and i actually found this myself the
other day i was having a bit of a bad
day i can't remember what happened to me
ah it was last week sometime but i was a
bit like i was just a bit
everything was just annoying me
basically um i went to the chiropractors
i was driving there was a car in front
of me it was really slow
and annoying making me late and it was
just like ah and then
at the end of the day i just thought you
know i've been like kind of
being annoyed and in this funk all day
but
when i was thinking like oh the moments
the things i could be grateful for at
least i have a car
i was in a nice car driving be grateful
for my car
um it's true and you know i was going to
the chiropractor
some people don't even go to the
chiropractors it really helps your back
and stuff
be grateful for that i don't know i just
think i was just being a bit
so anyway yeah just be grateful for
little things and find something to be
grateful for is what i would say so
why why do you go to the chiropractor i
go to the cafe
you don't need to go no no i don't have
a bad back it's because so i was
pregnant and then after
pregnancy so when you're pregnant your
pelvis and stuff shifts and things like
that
and at the moment i'm breastfeeding so
my posture i'm like constantly bending
over like this so
i just go to have adjustments just to
make me be all aligned and stuff so
well you are beautifully aligned smart
attractive and
lots of wisdom so i think every week i'm
going to ask you that question don't
don't act like you didn't expect yeah
i'm gonna come here
guys thank you so much for watching drop
a comment drop a question
smash the like button and we will see
you next time with what we think
is going to be called the leeds family
money marriage and life if you like the
name
let us know down below see you next time
thanks for watching guys bye
you